he started on this show 2 and a half
years ago was living in his van now he
literally sells out all over the world
every single weekend he has been getting
challenged for his spots a lot he is
going unchallenged tonight he is up
against uh golden ticket winner Rick
Diaz on the New Year's Eve show in which
one will be a full-time regular and the
other will not be allowed to perform on
the show anymore it's what they wanted
it's the fight that was created last
week I can't believe it going un
challenge tonight with a brand new 60
seconds not easy to write a new minute
every week the kid is an autistic Asian
Prodigy you guys know the words to his
theme song Get It Started you guys
[Applause]
started
everybody thank
you I have been applying for a job as a
makeup artist on BET cuz I want to get
better at drawing
blackface I love Mexicans Mexico is such
a thin skinny little country that when
Mexicans come to America they're like oo
am I going to be an East Coast Mexican
or a West Coast
Mexican and then a coyote
decides it's like a Mexican Sorting
Hat congratulations you're in House El
Paso I am uh dating a beautiful white
woman as a lot of you guys know and uh
thank you she recently went on a cruise
and I was kind of worried about it but
she showed me this app that shows
exactly where in the ocean she's getting
[__] by a Jamaican
[Laughter]
dude thank you wow look at
the professional Hans Kim doing exactly
60 seconds not a second more that's
right saving it absolutely how's it
going Hans it's going great I didn't
know that if I lost a challenge I
couldn't perform on kill Tony wow well
that that must have been fun to find out
seconds before I brought you on stage
that seems to be what the challenge felt
like to me I mean it was uh originally
him challenging you for regular ship but
it seemed like you had nothing to lose
if you lost so it seems like a fun thing
are you more nervous now no I'm pretty
confident wow all right I guess I
believe you you know what's interesting
if he gets beat like before then that
person's going to have to battle Rick
Diaz what are you talking about like
like if like if he gets challenged next
week like if he gets challenged next
week and loses he's not he thank you Red
Band thank you so much let's get back to
the
show uh so did your girl really go on a
cruise yeah okay was it really to
Jamaica yes uh she's so far unmolested I
don't think she's had sex um she's she's
back from the cruise right yes she she
just came back um we tried a little fun
little game that I like to call ano uh o
combined it with my other favorite game
rape and ah have you combined the two
games yet
yes been red band all right there goes
the fart board for the
episode our relationship has been great
you know we recently went to a strip
club with the great sha Ali
wow I love it how was that she was
mostly in the car uh you left your
girlfriend in the car while you went
into a strip club with with the current
UFC champion of the world yeah I left
the windows roll down
so oh my God how long do you think you
were in this strip club with your girl
in the car probably like an hour wow and
then she came out yeah she I let her you
know go pee in the
bushes no what really happened come on
well she went in and uh she drank some
water and uh stared at the strippers and
criticized some of
them and then she went right back in the
car incredible uh Hans now you're
famously cheap did you spend any money
at this strip club whatsoever I did
spend some money but it was Nick money
uh the owner of the Vulcan okay wow look
at that hell yeah there he is absolutely
how much of Nick's money did you spend
probably like 50 bucks oh wow still
cheap cheap even with other people's
money incredible 50 bucks an
unbelievably low amount of money to
spend this was at the red rose yellow
rose okay perfect absolutely the rose
preferred by Asians the Yellow
Rose let's go back to this anal thing
for a second cuz this is brand new let's
switch from yellow to Brown here and uh
what's going on you've been doing that
is that nice do you like that does she
like that she uh doesn't sound like she
likes it oh wow this is pretty much a
sexual assault on a podcast right
now what's the sound that she makes that
makes you think she doesn't like it just
like no stop oh my God oh my
God oh my
God no
[Laughter]
Hans uh
really yes and we we cuddle afterwards
and talk it out and
debrief
[Laughter]
[Music]
debrief wow okay H how how does it feel
for you do you enjoy it yeah it's uh you
know really tight at the you know where
where you go
in yeah I bet her [__] virgin [__]
is really
tight and then once get in it's like a
empty Cavern in
there oh my God an empty Cavern I'm sure
she just loves you talking about the
inside of her [__] like
this uh you guys uh ever seen Hans
before what do you think about Hans I
have seen Hans I'm a fan of H I mean now
I'm a little off-put by Hans
but I do enjoy his comedy but it's nice
of you to to snuggle post rape I
think I think rape victims like that
from what
I've
heard no I'm kidding I know you're
kidding I'm kidding Hans you're a
fantastic comedian it's great to see you
thank you J absolutely sugar Sean I
[__] love Hans are those glasses
prescription yes are they I'm really
feel like you take them off your eyes
get like when you put them on they just
like open up a little bit more is that
right w
wow look at that oh Tre
we is that how they work they just open
your eyes up more it's it sort of
magnifies it a little bit [__] love
you Hans thank you Sean it was it was
like when you took the glasses off it
was like the romcom where the girl takes
the glasses off you become a better
looking guy when you take them off it's
actually incredible and if Redban was
able to do his job properly I would be
able to show you exactly why don't you
try it again for the
audience it's a different it's a
different Dream
Weaver he did not spell it properly so
again Red Band just absolutely bad at
his job it's incredible 10 years and 4
months never gets any better this song
uh doesn't exist on here anymore uhhuh
yeah can't find Dream Weaver on the
internet everybody it's it doesn't exist
on the internet it could not be red band
it must be the internet everybody waa
oh oh my God we went from sugar Shan to
Soy
Sauce holy [__] he looks like sugar
shano
marry went from UFC to MSG look at this
oh
my wow somehow they didn't seem Asian
when they were on
seot
oh my
God absolutely
amazing I feel like I can knock out aljo
right
now wow wow maybe come on out eljo
yeah incredible maybe you could uh play
a game of anal rape with him or
something like that oh you ready take
him off now let's see what
happens
there we go 8 minutes later we figured
it out
uh yeah I know it's two words that's
what happens when the [__] thing
doesn't pop up um Hans another exact
minute for you uh you are so fun way to
get the show started every single week
amazing stuff we love you Hans Kim
everybody there
goes we pulled a name out to get it
started I'm going to pull another one
while we get through this one in here